I'm pretty sure you all know that I'm a
small government guy.
What's small government means to me,
at least economically is that you should
keep most of what you earn and that you
yourself are the best arbiter to decide
where your money goes,
whether the money you are and goes to
fixing your house or buying a new car or
to funding planned parenthood and
supporting Lincoln Center.
I believe that should be up to you.
You've worked hard for your money,
I assume,
and I believe that you're a better judge
of how to spend it rather than giving it
to a wasteful government,
which will often spend it on programs
that you don't even care about.
At the same time,
being for small government isn't only
about taxes and economics at its root.
Being for small government is also about
being for the individual.
I believe that your faculty to
understand how you want to live is far
better than anyone else's faculty on how
you should live your life.
At the same time,
I understand the need for the government
is different depending on whether you
live in a rural area or an urban center.
For example,
in a rural area with less people,
there is most likely less of a need for
regulation than there is in an urban
area.
Take something as simple as a noise
ordinance.
If you live in a remote,
rural area in the middle of the country,
there is most likely no need for a law
to stop people from doing construction
in the middle of the night or blasting
their music too loudly.
But if you live in an urban center,
Say New York City where people live in
small apartments on top of one another.
A noise ordinance might be important to
you.
You can't have construction people
knocking down walls at all hours of the
night and you might not want your
neighbor blasting music at 3:00
AM.
The next piece of the limited government
puzzle is whether or not the government
needs to be involved in so many facets
of our lives at all.
Even in the case of New York City with
it's cramped conditions and tiny living
spaces,
is it the government who has to tell
companies not to do construction in the
middle of the night or tenants not to
blast music at ungodly hours?
This is where an interesting discussion
can happen.
Is it the job of the government as laid
out by the constitution,
which I think we're still governed by to
regulate these interpersonal issues,
or is it the job of individuals to deal
with these issues themselves?
Should a building in New York City have
a policy about noise instead of leaving
it to the government?
Should it be incumbent on you to talk to
your neighbor about the volume of their
music rather than leaving it to the
government?
Can issues we think of traditionally
being dealt with by the government
actually be dealt with in the private
sector or is the government already too
deep into controlling us that we could
never scale it back without burning down
the system?
While noise ordinances aren't the most
pressing issue out there?
Obviously I use it as a simple example
of the battle between the private and
the public and how sometimes we assign
power to the government when perhaps
there could be a better option based in
our own capacity to reason for
ourselves.
With all this in mind,
we're continuing our partnership with
learn liberty this week and me is best
selling author and economist at George
Mason University,
Bryan Caplan.
Brian is in a narco capitalists,
which in simple terms is an extreme
libertarian who wants government pretty
much out of everything.
We'll talk about taxes,
healthcare,
rent control,
and much more and see if there are
places that the private sector can
actually do a better job than what the
public has been able to do.
Now,
according to us,
penal code four,
two nine.
Pursuant to the laws of the state in
which you are governed,
you are hereby ordered to click like and
comment down below.
We're continuing our partnership with
learn liberty this week,
and joining me today is a professor of
economics at George Mason University,
an author and a narco capitalist.
End a pacifist Brian Kaplan.
Welcome to the Rubin report.
Thanks a lot for having me.
Lot of good buzzwords in there and we're
going to get to all of them,
but first,
what's it like being a professor on
campus these days that doesn't identify
as a progressive?
Is that tough?
Are you getting rocks thrown at you
every day?
How's that gone?
My life is perfectly fine.
Nothing's ever had.
Nothing bad's ever happened to be.
I don't even know.
I've never gotten a negative comment on
a student evaluation.
To be fair,
I'm in the Economics Department at
George Mason University,
which is a very unusual place.
There's a lot of libertarian and free
market oriented people there,
but also what I say is that the stories
that you hear on the media while
generally true,
if you remember how many people are on
campus,
how many professors there are,
so if every week you see some horrible
thing happens to one professor that
still leaves the 99 point nine,
nine,
nine percent of all professors who had a
perfectly find week and so far so good
for me.
Yeah,
and you make a point of saying you're in
the economics department,
which is probably insulated from some of
this stuff's because you have to work
with facts and figures and numbers.
These are sort of outside of the realm
of where social justice can hit.
Right?
Right.
So just know economics says a long
history of field where you can say
really controversial and shocking things
and people are curious and want to talk
about it in a civilized way rather than
get really mad at you.
So I'd say at least half of the
controversial ideas in academia have
come out of economics and economists get
Nobel prizes for these ideas.
It's,
you know,
Gary Becker and Milton Friedman.
It's not like people are waiting around
for you to say the wrong thing and jump
on you,
uh,
you said to me then you have the real
difference is just people who are very
dull.
There are.
Economists were very boring,
but it's not like they're angry at
people for doing other stuff.
They're just not doing really exciting
work.
But there's plenty of room in economics
for people to say almost anything
really.
And not only get away with it,
but to succeed,
meaning I mean,
mean,
I've long been telling people like,
if you really want to be a professor,
tried to figure out how to repackage
what you're,
what you want to do with economics,
and then just get a Phd Phd economics,
you'll make more money,
you'll get tenure or you'll get an
email,
you'll get a job easily and you'll be in
a very supportive atmosphere.
We can say you want,
I can tell you truly believe in the free
market because you're welcoming people
to take your job right now.
That's a,
that's pretty good.
Ten years.
So I'm not that worried in that way.
But um,
and also remember that the more people
in order for in order to become a vestry
first have to become one of my customers
and go to Grad school.
So naturally it's not as on self
interest might seem.
Yeah.
Do you find that professors of
economics,
either George Mason or you were just
mentioning a debate,
you're doing it in a couple of days,
that generally professors of economics
from whatever,
uh,
you know,
whatever pathology they believe in,
uh,
are able to debate and it doesn't get
personal and it can really stick on the
issues and that kind of thing.
So,
uh,
in general I'd say yes.
Again,
the main problem is just people who are
not interested in bigger ideas and only
want to focus on their research topics.
So people like that are not touchy.
They're not hostile,
they're just apathetic or they use.
Sometimes they'll have the idea of,
you know,
what you are doing is not science and I
don't really care about that and you
don't belong here,
but it's not that they disagree with
what you're saying as they disagree with
people taking on bigger questions of any
kinds.
So that,
I mean,
again,
that's sort of what I've dealt with in
my time in academia is just I want to do
big exciting ideas.
And a lot of economists frown on that,
not because they disagree with the
content because they disagree with
anything.
Begging.
Exciting.
Yeah.
So before we get into some of your big
and exciting ideas,
do you find that generally outside of
the universities that just the American
populace really doesn't understand
anything about economics because this is
what I see all the time,
you know,
I can only garner so much information
from social media,
but I see people saying things about
trade all the time and immigration all
the time and all these things that are
tied back into economics and I'm like,
you don't really seem to know much about
anything.
Yeah.
So I have a whole book on this called
the myth of the rational voter democracy
issues,
bad policies in the book.
I just go over all the evidence on what
does the public actually believe about
economics compared to what anyone who
can explain the textbook.
Thanks.
And yeah,
it's terrible.
Why do you think about it is so mean.
Right now we're in la.
I grew up here,
so I will say that until I was 17,
I never heard any argument against the
minimum wage.
I never heard any argument against
regulation of pharmaceuticals.
I don't think I ever heard any argument
against the welfare state ever.
And again,
I was not growing up in Berkeley or some
some left wing haven.
I've just growing up in a normal,
boring middle class suburb here in Los
Angeles.
But the kinds of arguments that
economists make and are aware of are
just not even on people's radar.
So that's an important distinction that
you just said there that you didn't grow
up in Berkeley.
You grew up in a suburb of Los Angeles.
That's somewhat blue collar.
Elliot middle,
middle class,
the middle class,
yeah,
it was,
it was probably could easily been half
Republican in days and still like I'd
never heard any of the very basic
economic arguments critiquing standard
popular regulations.
You Indian.
So it's like everyone really like,
you know,
talking to my parents about rent control
and you know,
they didn't understand anything about
the economist critique of rent control
and how it caused.
How it causes a shortage in housing for
them,
it's just like,
well we own a rental property so we're
against it.
It was sort of all that they could come
up with.
Right.
Uh,
so you know,
this is,
this is very,
very standard for the,
you know,
not just the American public but the
global,
but the global public and throughout
history is just like the very basic
ideas of economics that are in every
textbook are not known and when they're
heard this is this regular thing.
So it's one thing to never heard them,
but northern normal reaction is just
anger.
So I say,
well they're so insulated from any other
idea basically.
Right.
And also it just like,
it just like,
why are you saying this while?
Can't we have the minimum wage?
It's a program to go and help poor
people.
And then an economist comes along and
says there's a downside.
This could cause unemployment.
And people's reaction is how could you
say something like that?
So that's so terrible.
Or only what kind of like you hate,
you hate poor people.
And again,
this seems like a parody,
but I have experienced this firsthand
plenty of time.
What have you do with that?
What do you do with that?
When you try to lay out something and
you say,
well,
here's data to support it,
but it's so emotional to somebody else.
Something like minimum wage or you
usually I try to connect it to versed
and experienced because the only time I
talk about,
uh,
talking about the data,
then someone could say,
well,
it's your data.
Like how do I do?
There must be plenty of other people
have other data.
So trying to say,
well look,
when you fill out a job application,
you get to the line on salary
requirements.
You put a million dollars an hour.
No,
why not?
Well,
because,
uh,
I think if I put too much money then I'm
less likely to get the job.
Ah Ha.
So it's not just me that believes that
if wages are too high,
that unemployment result,
you believe it too.
It's just that you don't want to connect
what you know from your own experience
to the world of policy because it
doesn't sound good.
Yeah.
I think it's interesting what you said
about your parents.
They had a rental property so they
didn't like rent control because
obviously you don't want it if you're
the owner of the property and how we,
how we all apply our own life might be
separate from what our philosophical
principles are.
Yeah.
Because I lived in New York City for
about 12 years in an apartment that was
rent stabilized,
so it's slightly different than right.
Controlled,
but they could only increase my rent.
I think something like,
you know,
would change every few years,
but about two percent a year,
which for me as the tenant was great and
they,
you know,
over the course of 12 years,
my rent when I started at 1650 for a two
bedroom apartment on the upper west and
I think it maxed out at about 2000.
So as the tenant on my side,
that's pretty great.
Make the argument why I'm wrong about
that.
Yes.
Uh,
so in terms of your own self interest,
you might,
might be perfectly right.
I mean they're,
I mean I would say,
well there are some downsides.
Things like quality tends to go down
with rent control,
so know like the heating,
the heating breaks down and you can
never fix a couple things.
So,
so there is that,
uh,
so you know,
this,
this is just,
you know,
very standard result with any kind of
price controls.
If you can't adjust on the price then
you can adjust on all these other and
all these other ways to adjust unquality
a bot or are you going to,
you can try charging people for extras,
things like that.
But yeah,
I mean,
so like you know,
there's always going to be people who do
benefit from the policies and if you
happen to be that person then it's very
elegant.
Like you might say it hard to know the
saving grace is that in general people
are not comfortable arguing for
political policy or policies on self
hearsay.
The grounds some,
you know,
when you were saying,
look,
this is very bad for society.
People normally want to dispute that
that is bad for society.
They don't want to say,
well sure it's bad for society,
but I'm one of them in the minority of
people are benefiting from this,
so I like it and we should have it.
Yeah,
you know,
it's interesting.
I think the point that you make there
about,
well they're going to have to cut in
other ways if they can't raise your
rent.
So for example,
in my building in the winter,
every winter there would literally be,
if,
if we were in the middle of a storm,
there would be three or four days in a
row where we would not have heat.
It was an old steam heat,
four story building and there was a
couple days when I was single back then
that I literally was under the covers
with my dog because I didn't want her to
freeze either and I went to the,
to the management building,
which is a couple blocks away and I was
basically reaming them out and I
remember the woman was sitting behind
bulletproof glass and this is what's
wrong with this system.
This woman,
she works for a big company,
they own 500 buildings were stuck under
this.
I never fully connected that to rent
control or rent stabilization,
not inclined to move out to a full plate
price place that had good heat.
Yeah.
So that does show how we all sort of
negotiate these strange things.
So let's talk about a narco capitalist.
All right?
Because I haven't done much on it.
I think I've had one in Norco
capitalist,
my friend that guy t on on youtube.
You should check out if you don't know
him.
Great guy in Atlanta.
Um,
what is a narco capitalism.
So enter.
Oh,
capitalism is the idea that these so
called minimal functions to the states
are actually more than you really need.
And it's,
it is not only imaginable butts,
you know,
it could,
but it really could work to prioritize
the last lingering functions of
government like police courts and the
law itself.
And this is it.
This sounds really crazy.
So the way that I usually like to
explain it is,
well,
right now people may say,
well government clearly sms,
monopoly over police,
monopoly,
overclock over courts,
monopoly over law,
and I say government has a monopoly over
these things right now.
Right now there's actually more private
security guards and police.
So is that.
That's true.
So you know there are,
there are more people hired by business
and communities to go and do policing.
Then there are police in the,
in the official sense.
And then you know.
So for courts there is a huge area of
private adjudication.
There's arbitration,
there is anytime you have a problem with
your credit card,
do you sue the company?
This involved?
No.
You called the credit card company and
they have their own internal
adjudication system for handling things
like this on facebook.
If you have problems on facebook,
do you go into facebook?
No.
You Go,
you go and you,
when you complain with them and they do
something about it,
and then essentially they really do
something about it in the case of
facebook,
but maybe we'll say,
well,
it's the minimum.
They give you a bunch of options to
solve your own problem.
You can block someone,
you can unfriend them,
you can make sure that they never
contact you again.
So you know,
they give you a bunch of remedies that
you have,
which are,
you know,
they've worked out exactly what it is
they want to do about it.
And then,
you know,
similarly for your,
for learning a lot self,
there are many private organizations
that have their own rules that they
apply.
So again,
mentioning I'll be up.
So private arbitration,
you know,
one of the main reasons people use
private arbitration is that they don't
use regular laws.
They use their own laws which are
designed to work better than the
government's law so that you can get
your issue resolved in a few days
instead of weeks or years.
Uh,
so,
you know,
like usually with a pro,
with private arbitration,
they have the arbitrator.
Actually be someone who knows what he's
doing,
so they have someone who is in fact an
expert on this area of business ceos
rather than giving it to a generalist
and 12 people who were,
who were too dumb to get out of jury
duty.
Uh,
so just,
just sort of beginning realizing,
wow,
this.
So there's a lot of private,
more private alternatives that already
exists right now to,
you know,
to government providing these services
that at first glance,
a lot of people just have the reaction
of it with justice society,
which is burned in flames.
If there were private police or private
cloud or private courts are private law.
Look around.
It's not burning now and there's already
a very large role for the private
sector.
So.
And then we will.
What I think,
you know,
what I think about anarcho capitalist
and I always just say,
all right,
well let's start when we got you realize
that that is not going to lead anything
bad.
And there's very good reasons why people
are using these private alternatives
right now,
which is they're better,
they're worth the money you get,
you know,
you actually get a,
you get a better quality for all four
of,
you know,
not only for a lower price,
but remember,
these are private companies competing
with free government services and
they're still carving out a big market
niche for themselves because so many
people are so dissatisfied with these
services,
they get provided free by the
government.
And then just thinking about like,
how much further can we take these?
So,
you know,
very easy with,
with,
uh,
with private arbitration,
right now,
one of the big limits on private
arbitration is that even if you sign a
so called binding arbitration clause,
in fact,
if the,
uh,
have the person that is,
if a person doesn't like how the binding
arbitration turns out,
they can go and they can,
yes,
they can take it works.
So for example,
if you sighing binding arbitration
saying,
know in the event of any of any
employment to dispute,
it's going to,
this will be handled by private
arbitration.
Uh,
you know,
like that contract in general isn't like
while it might get a forced,
there's no,
there's no confidence that would be.
And again,
if you think about it,
well yeah,
I mean like suppose that you could sign
this binding arbitration.
I could get my brother in law to go and
be the arbitrator.
He always rules in my favor.
You could use this to get around a great
many government laws so you can
understand why government doesn't want
to do this and yet clearly you could go
and allow a lot more room for private
arbitration and,
and I,
and actually it is likely that there is
immense,
immense pent up demand for private
arbitration that is right now being
stifled by regulation.
Right.
And then Uln,
once you start thinking about how could
there be even more ideal,
you know,
so like one,
like one obvious one to me is you go
into government courts and they say,
well actually if this,
if this is a private contract,
we just just required,
you just have to have an arbitration
clause and it's not our problem,
you know,
so like,
no,
they're like you're so if you want,
if you want adjudication,
put an arbitration clause.
And all we do,
there's this butte is so it's the
contract that says this is the
arbitrator rubber stamp.
That's it.
Yeah.
So maybe as an intermediate,
intermediate step you would keep
criminal stuff exact.
Exactly.
Move some of this stuff that's purely
mentally bay.
Exactly.
So then when you just start thinking
about all the things that you can hand
over to the private sector to the
private sector,
you know,
it is much larger than what pf and went
through the what,
what occurs the first.
And then the anarcho capitalist idea is
really once we,
once we have privatized all the things
that at first it seemed like you
couldn't,
but we just keep going further and
further and further the end.
You're left with almost nothing.
And then the question is,
could you just get rid of that last
bit's.
So let's,
let's pause on the left side for a
second because you mentioned a few
different areas there.
So I think the arbitration one's really
interesting.
I'm wondering when you see cases of
arbitration now,
uh,
it must self select a certain type of
person to go ahead and do that.
What type of things are being fought in
arbitration?
You know what I mean?
Like you'd have,
I guess you'd probably have to have a
certain amount of money you would not
want to maybe know that the person
across the table from you is in a
similar situation or has similar views
that they'd be willing to accept it
because you just said right at the end
they could probably figure out a way to
get this back into the courts.
I mean,
it's fairly common actually.
Just add it in as boiler plate into a
contract saying it will be arbitrated,
but the people who really wanted I
think,
or people have been burned by lawsuits
in the past,
people who've seen business deals as
collapsed before their eyes because the
dispute came up and they didn't work it
out and then it took years for them to
go and resolve it.
And by then the business was bankrupt.
So the OCR or course if you've been sued
by an employee and you think you and I
didn't even think it was bogus.
That's another thing.
Like I never want that to happen again.
So these are the,
like some obvious cases and putting it
in.
But you know,
chorusy like no employer is thrilled
about the idea of getting sued.
So like yelling and like if it were the
kind of thing that you could really rely
on,
then you know,
I say I think it's very likely that it
would be like totally standard to put in
private arbitration and just to avoid or
like all like all the hassles that are
involved with hiring people right now.
Um,
you know,
of course,
if you think these laws are good,
then this is very distressing to you.
On the other hand,
to someone like me,
the fact that almost everyone would
probably happily sign away the right to
sue their employer shows there's
something very curt,
very bad about the system we have.
It's like,
look,
it's the kind of thing that you have the
right to sue employers.
That kind of right.
The people will sign away for a small
amount of money,
which means that it's probably not a
very valuable right to begin with.
It's the kind of thing that you're stuck
with and it's in so many ways it's a
burden because then you have to convince
an employer,
I'm not going to sue you.
I'm,
I'm cool.
And well,
isn't it also that the average person
who works for even a small company,
not just a giant corporation,
we don't have lawyers on retainer.
So I work for myself now,
which is a pretty beautiful thing,
but I've worked at plenty of companies
where the day I got hired I had to sign
some crazy book of all the pressure and
of course I didn't read all that stuff.
So it's like I'm not walking around with
our lawyer and most people are.
So many people are just signing stuff
without even knowing what they're
saying.
Which I would say is thank goodness for
that because if people were actually,
people are actually taking it more
seriously and you'll see where you are
right now.
I think,
you know,
firms are taking advantage of that to
get to go and diluted as much as the law
will allow.
And again,
I think there's a sense.
I think the regulations are bad in the
first place.
I'm all for people diluting the
regulations as much as possible.
So there's an old saying,
thank God we don't get as much
government to be paid for.
I say also,
thank God we don't sue people to
anywhere near the extent that we legally
could because it would be a hellish
world.
Yeah.
This may sound like a very amateur
question,
but when people go into arbitration,
are you bringing a lawyer with you or is
it just that the arbitrator is just
looking at what was signed and deciding?
Like is there an actual argument that's
taking place?
So I think it varies a lot so sometimes
you might bring a lawyer so you know,
so we'd like.
It may actually depend upon the rules of
the arbitration,
but you know,
I think a lot of the ideas just to cut
the expenses down so the.
A lot of times you don't have a lawyer,
you just have an arbitrator there who
generally is well versed in the industry
that you're working in so he actually
knows what you're talking about.
And then of course you know part of what
they're doing.
So there's something more moderate
called mediation where the arbitrator
doesn't matter where the person doesn't
really get to decide anything but just
tries to get the two people to talk.
It's kind of like counseling and then
arbitration is stronger where he listens
to both sides and then he tells you
about what's going to be.
Is there a set time frame on how long
that lasts?
No,
no.
Certainly not always a.
Since this is private,
there's,
you know,
there's a wide range.
There's a beautiful rainbow of all
possibilities so we know which are all
done.
So you know,
there's,
you know,
sometimes there's an arbitrator who just
says looking at like we need tomorrow.
That's it Robert.
And that story,
here's what's gonna happen.
And even part of the beauty of that is
once you get the dispute resolved,
a lot of times you can go back to
working with each other.
We may not be that happy about it,
but it's like there's no longer an
ongoing dispute and so it's settled and
then he can get back to business and you
haven't paid and insane amount to
lawyers.
Lawyers aren't thrilled with the.
Yeah,
yeah.
Probably not immediately.
So of course their sob who are
entrepreneurial enough to see,
well this is an opportunity for me to
branch out,
but yeah,
I think it would be very bad for lawyers
in the,
in the long running.
And of course,
for litigators particularly,
which is a small minority of lawyers in
the first place,
but uh,
you know,
assuming like,
like for a contract lawyer,
this might be awesome because then
people,
then there'd be a bunch of people who
want to rewrite all their contracts to
go and putting by putting binding
arbitration that's truly and utterly
binding.
Right.
Uh,
so you mentioned earlier that even
policing could be pressurized,
but what would happen?
So I can understand that a place like
beverly hills people got a lot of money.
We're going to prioritize the Beverly
Hills Police Department.
Beverly Hills Cop.
Okay.
I saw the movie that wasn't what the
movie was about,
but I had to get that in there somehow.
But what wasn't a place?
What about in a place where they're at,
where the economics are terrible,
where people have no money,
we're probably crime is the highest.
Who,
who's going to put in money to.
How are you gonna make a profit off
that.
Yeah.
So,
um,
you know,
keeping,
you realize.
So those places work where crime is
terrible or ones where the current
police already don't work very well.
So we're just,
we're stepping back and realizing the
current system is quite grumpy to begin
with now.
Like you know,
who would pay for it otherwise.
So again,
the obvious place to start are people
actually are landlords.
So like in a more suburban area,
you're talking about homeowners
associations are some of the obvious
people to pay for it,
but you know,
even now in that area is very common for
landlords to pay for some kind of
security.
And if they know that it's their job to
do it in a high crime area,
you'll even someone who is poor is
galliano values their life values
protection.
So you know,
like sort of like a,
like an economist joke has been like,
you know,
you see a lot of really expensive
sneakers and bad areas down,
but why is this?
Well like when it's a priority,
people will come up with the money in
order to pay for things that they really
care about.
But you know,
the other thing about policing is,
I mean I think it's also better to think
about it and in a broader category of
just enforcement of all kinds.
So there's many kinds of enforcement
besides actual police.
So one that's become very common with
the Internet is the all kinds of
reputational incentives.
So you know,
like,
you know,
just like bad reviews,
things like this,
you know,
these work far better than like the FDA.
So you like imagine you get a bad meal,
do you go and call it the FDA and
complain about it or something like that
or like local meat inspectors know,
like much more likely to go and put in a
bad yelp review.
And this is the way that we are probably
getting most of our actual enforcements.
You know,
like you like how,
what is protecting you from food
poisoning?
Is it the government now?
The government's hardly doing anything
about it.
What's really protecting you from food
poisoning is always word of mouth,
which is now amplified because there's
no.
Now it is word of the Internet.
One,
one complaints.
So you're like,
my dad runs an internet business,
like one disgruntled customer is
terrible for you and is really a much
more effective enforcement mechanism
than anything in the government is doing
about it.
So some of it that it just,
the messaging has to be clear because
that concept seems very obvious to me in
a day of the Internet where you're
right,
people care now more about what a yelp
review of a restaurant says than what
either a written review in the La Times
says or what,
uh,
you know,
what it says at the restaurant,
what they're telling you themselves.
So we,
that this is really about messaging in a
way more than economics because I think
people can get there economically.
Yeah.
And then again also just thinking about
ways that you can get a contract between
people that you don't ordinarily think
of as a,
as a contractual relationship.
So right now we also like,
if you get an accident with someone
you'd only car accident.
You don't have,
you don't have a contract with the
person who got an accident with.
But if you both have insurance,
your insurance company has a
relationship with their insurance
company.
So when,
you know,
of course,
most auto accidents never go to trial.
The insurance companies have a system
that they work out where they negotiate
with each other,
they've got standards.
So again,
that's,
that's already going on.
And then just think about anytime you're
in a public place,
anytime you're in a mall,
so you,
like you are right now,
of course,
if there's a dispute there,
the police will handle it.
But it is very easy to visualize a world
where when you go to the mall,
there's actually a sign saying like,
Yo,
so when you enter this,
you come under the jurisdiction of this
arbitration company and Alice.
And then any dispute that happens in
them all then is no longer actually
needs to be handled by the police.
Uh,
so,
you know,
and,
and of course people saying,
well,
I mean,
they're just ran a cops,
you know,
they don't even have,
a lot of them don't ever really have
guns.
I mean,
of course if the taxpayers will pay for
someone to be shot at than pe companies
are not going to pay or not going to pay
the extra amount to have their
employees.
So the whole system of economics,
we sort of flipped if we.
Yeah.
So I mean,
you know,
the amazing thing about all of the kinds
of private of private law that we see
right now,
isn't that how little it does,
but how much it does given that the
government provides these services free
of charge and people still,
I will take money out of their own
pockets to go rather than go and get the
free stuff.
Which yeah.
All right.
So you know,
of course,
you know,
and so you know,
it's always the incense,
it's not free because you have to pay
taxes,
but in another sense it is free.
Namely you can use it without any
additional charge.
So that's the sense in which this stuff
is free.
Like sometimes they'll like,
you'll get charged for a false alarm,
although that's pretty unusual.
But like the fire departments sometimes
you call them for no reason.
They'll sit,
they'll give you a,
a bales.
I like,
why did you go and waste valuable
services?
But normally that's not how it works.
You mentioned a car insurance.
Where does health insurance fall on
this?
Because how the Germans right now is
making everyone completely insane.
Uh,
no matter what side you're on,
everyone is crazy about this.
So,
so what is then the answer for health
insurance in your view?
Right.
Uh,
well I guess that's probably the last
question I'll ask you for the interview.
So no health insurance.
So you know,
I like,
I have the extreme view that there's no
reason for government to be involved in
this area at all.
And what's very striking is that while
most economists officially sell will
disagree,
but when,
when,
when I've actually got an argue with
them,
usually when they argue for regulation,
they're arguing for regulations to fix
other regulations.
And when I say,
well,
what if we just didn't have the first
regulations are trying to fix,
then the reaction is kind of like,
well I never really thought about it
that much.
So just for example,
the,
you know,
the whole idea of Obamacare,
is that all right?
Well first we're going to have a
regulation saying that you can't turn
people down for insurance.
And secondly,
we're gonna have a regulation saying
that you can't charge them higher prices
and then people normally realize,
well,
wait a second,
you a system like that,
that a lot of people just wait around
until they're sick and so then we're
going to require people to buy
insurance,
to avoid the problems created by the new
regulations.
And then we're gonna.
Then there's people too poor to afford
it.
So then we're going to subsidize those
people to deal with the other three
regulations.
All right?
So,
um,
you know,
my view is there's really no reason why
you couldn't have scrapped all the
regulation and just said,
look,
here's your incentive by insurance.
If you wait until you're sick,
you won't be able to afford it.
But then what do you do for those
people?
So,
so I guess I get that,
but isn't,
than what,
what happens as a result of that is that
x amount of people,
and it's going to be a lot of people
simply will not do it because they'd
rather spend their money elsewhere and
hope that there'll be healthy or,
or they'll just get a broken leg playing
basketball or something else or
whatever.
Uh,
and then we still end up paying for
them.
Right?
Don't address them,
will automatically end up paying for
them.
Not automatically.
Again,
if you get rid of all those regulations,
then then for service and then you have
to rely on charity.
And of course charity includes family
includes everybody else that might want
to help you,
but that you'll say,
well that's terrible.
I wouldn't want to have to deal with
that.
Yes.
That's why you buy insurance and
advances because you don't want to be
put in that position.
Right?
So of course then you started late start
thinking about the horrible cases.
Like what about a child boards,
they're responsible parents and the
child is a lifelong congenital disease.
I say that's the kind of thing that
charities are going to be very well
equipped to handle.
They're probably not going to be so
equipped to handle someone who's 25 and
was earning a middle class income.
It didn't feel like buying insurance and
then they come down with a horrible
problem.
Those are ones where I think you're
likely to be very low in priority and
it's world like you're an adult and it
was your responsibility to take care of
yourself.
Uh,
but sort of in the background is the
issue of like,
how can you be so callous as to say if
you went and did something really dumb
that it's just your own tough luck.
And so I have this old blog post called
tough luck,
right?
So you know what every political
philosophy ultimately says tough luck to
people.
It's just a question of where they draw
the line.
So you know there's the,
well,
what if there's a conservative go
conservative government power and they
can skip my son and he sent to another
country and you get Eddie dies.
What happens then?
And of course the conservative answer is
ultimately,
well,
tough luck.
That's the system like in my system,
you can be conscripted if I didn't
worry,
you don't want to.
And sometimes when that happens you get
put into a lethal area and you die.
And like,
well my life has been ruined and what
are you going to do about it?
Nothing.
And they'll give you a plaque or similar
yellow or the yellow like,
you know,
similarly like,
like,
you know,
like even someone who is these a
supporter in the world of socialized
medicine.
So what if a person goes and cuts off
their own legs and then.
And then whenever you go and send
someone to help them,
they throw things at them.
What are you going to do then?
Well then I guess tough luck all and
that person,
is this going to be alone and be
suffering because they wouldn't go along
with the system.
All right?
So given that every single philosophy
ultimately says tough luck.
I don't see why people who believe in
the free market should feel,
especially embarrassed to say,
well yeah,
my system.
This is where we draw the line and if
you have failed to do all of these
things than that,
it's here.
Then it's your problem because there is
no perfect system based.
There's no perfect system and and again
like would it be a perfect system if
someone could be completely
irresponsible 100 times in a row and
would still get treated like everybody
else?
Have they done any studies that you know
of where they've shown where in cases
that the government pulls back that
charity does take care of this stuff so
that in the case,
which I think is a legitimate.
Like philosophically,
I fully get what you're saying there
that if we just pulled back a little bit
that people would give more.
Is there evidence of that?
Because I just
so well so it's all.
Almost all the evidence is the other way
around where it's.
There used to be private charity and
then government started doing it and
then people measure what happened to the
charity that was involved.
This is called crowding out.
There's a whole field economic charity
when they study this,
and this is a totally standard result
that there are many areas that private
charity used to take care of,
like helping out the poor a demand now.
And as government expanded its role,
the role of private charity shrank down
and eventually,
eventually private charity moved into
other areas.
The government wasn't doing very much
about.
So yeah,
so you like in the thirties,
I was really only really use the
thirties or sort of when there was a big
transition because there were many
private organizations are things called
fraternal clubs and organizations that
were private clubs that did a lot of
things that the modern welfare state
does.
So if you lost your job that he,
they take care of you.
If there were sickness,
they go and take care of you.
Uh,
the thirties was single.
It was such a protractive depression and
depression that fight,
that partly started breaking down the
end.
But again,
a lot of it was government.
Taylor took over and once government
took over,
there really wasn't much point to belong
to the organizations anymore except to
go and put on funny hats and have one
once a month.
But you know,
like a lot.
A lot of these groups they like,
you remember your grandfather being part
of like the elks or the odd fellows.
These actually provided these welfare
state functions privately in the past.
So do you think that something like a
government funded planned parenthood,
which I'm sure regardless of your
feelings on abortion,
I'm sure you're not for the government
funding that I can accept that part.
So for myself,
I'm pro choice,
but when I see all these people talking
about public funding of all of these
things,
it does seem to me that if the
government stopped funding these things,
not made the illegal abortion but
stopped funding that this seems like a
case were so many people are so
passionate about it.
Oh,
all these people in Hollywood who are
constantly tweeting about this and
screaming.
Right.
But they would start funding these
things.
So is that a great example?
I think if anything,
it is a great example.
I mean you're the here,
you know,
here's the main thing that is troubling
about the economics of charity is
there's a bunch of cars of the people
that they care about and those.
I'm not worried about those.
There's gonna be plenty of money for
them.
There's a bunch of other terrible things
happening in the world that private
charity,
manifestly Evans hasn't solved.
It,
hasn't gone unsolved.
International refugee problems and you
know,
it's doing something but they're still
terrible things going on.
Isn't solved a hunger in other
countries.
You know,
the thing is that these are,
these are problems that taxpayers don't
care much about and that charitable gave
her some care very much about.
So not you'll say we can,
you know,
Bill Gates cares and you know,
he's,
you know,
he's making a single handily making a
noticeable in the problem.
But again,
so will sort of like the issues that
people are really concerned about.
The ones that have a lot of support for
taxpayers to do something about it,
about them are also very plausibly ones
were private donors.
We care a lot as well.
Yeah.
Is there any situation where you think
regulation is necessary?
Is there,
you know,
someone will.
I'm sure someone watching this is going
to comment.
Well,
what about the rivers?
They're going to pollute all the rivers
or anything.
Is there any instance where you see it
as.
Yeah.
So me,
what I would say is,
I don't know.
I would say so then,
you know,
the again,
so there's a lot of areas where given
the,
given Gary,
given the current setup,
it's very hard to see how,
like,
how,
like how either a for profit or even a
shared a response to it.
Uh,
again,
the question in my mind is always,
if we imagine going into privatizing
things that government to government,
Ngo,
government now does,
then what's left and then what's left
the charity can't handle.
So I mean,
and again that's to me like,
you know,
part of being an advocate of capitalist
is least saying,
well let's privatized and see before
saying there's no way that private
action are you going to handle this
problem.
Let's go and take and take a look.
And of course all the private solutions
may take a while to emerge,
but then again,
like,
you know,
like there are many problems the
government has dealt with very poorly so
far.
So I don't think it's fair to say after
a year,
you know,
private sector hasn't solved this yet,
so therefore clearly governments as
theory will let me give it some more
time.
But again,
like the ones that I think are the
clearest cases are,
you know,
air pollution.
So that's one where it's very hard to
exactly see how the privates,
like how for profit for profit sector
would handle it.
It's one where because air pollution
moves across the,
they're bullish moves.
Like there's like you,
you're not walking around in a bubble.
I get,
it's one where,
well again,
you're suppose that government didn't do
anything about it,
but there's private charity involved,
right?
Private charity to go and say subsidized
lower l,
lower polluting technologies or offer
prizes for lower,
lower polluting technologies and then
give away the patent so that these,
the new technologies are really cheap.
I'll get in.
So like us to like,
like how well that will work.
I honest,
I honestly would have to say it's so far
from where we are.
I don't know.
But I think we,
I think we should give it a try.
Yeah.
So most people watching this know that
I'm a limited government guy.
I believe in states rights.
I would always rather be governed by
the,
by my mayor and my local representative.
And then February will be governed by
the mayor of Los Angeles.
All right.
So you know,
he's a little,
he lives a little closer to me than the,
than the people in DC,
let's put it that way.
Regardless of my feelings of the mayor
of Los Angeles.
But generally speaking I want,
I believe in local,
local control.
So are there instances where local
control has done this better?
Like is there a,
is there a town you can point to or is
there a state maybe that's doing some of
this a little bit better?
Let's see.
So given that there are so many states
and localities,
I'm sure that there are,
I don't know off the top of the head
which,
which one,
which ones they are,
but yeah,
so like
is that partly just because the feds now
have so much control over everything?
It's hard for states to do that.
There is,
there is.
But again,
blank,
like you know,
so states do manage enormous amount.
I'd say the main issue actually is just
that the federal government provides so
much of the money for state governments
that a lot of the competitive pressure
that you think would be operating is it
has really been neutered by the fact
that states are just receive a bag of
money from the federal government for
certain purposes and if they aren't
allowed to and use it for other
purposes.
And so they have very little incentive
to try to figure out a way of saving
taxpayers and the taxpayers money on it.
And often the money of course comes a
lot of strings attached.
If you don't want this rings and you
have to give back all the money.
So very few places want to do that.
So what would you do in a case when,
uh,
you know,
when we hear about federal money being
used and everyone says,
okay,
so like for example,
like,
you know,
Hurricane Sandy Hits in New Jersey,
the Jersey shore is destroyed and then
Obama was probably hundreds of millions
of dollars.
I don't know off the top of my head or,
or a hurricane Katrina in New Orleans.
Do you again this would be the same
thing.
I think so like probably on private
insurance,
there's no reason that you couldn't have
private disaster insurance and of course
there is a lot of private jets or
insurance sold.
Normally the feds get in where this area
is so high risk that the insurance will
be really expensive and people will be
chomps don't feel like having to pay for
it.
And so either the Fed,
the feds take care of it or they
subsidize it and again,
like,
you know,
so we,
especially to me the idea that someone
with a beach house to get some
subsidized insurance because it's a
high,
it's a high disaster area around.
I like the disaster.
I'm always baffled by that.
They're limited in a beach house.
Why can't they?
Why can't a person in a beach house be
expected to buy their own insurance?
Well,
a lot of them do have insurance,
but they pay full market price for the
insurance.
So ultimately in a case like that would,
would people then be forced to move from
a place like.
So either you,
well,
here's what we want to really be forced
to move and tell the value of your home.
False now.
Yes,
but eventually maybe a self select out.
Yeah.
So I'm like really?
Like really what would happen given the
beach homes normally are very valuable,
is that those homes would just be worth
less because people realize if I move
into this home,
I'm gonna have to buy some really
expensive insurance.
So that doesn't sound very good.
So ultimately of the like,
you know,
like subsidizing disaster insurance is a
subsidy to people who develop in high
and high and disaster prone areas,
especially the on land in those areas
are ultimately the people who really
benefit from it because it raises the
value of that real estate's I guess I
never really thought about it in those
specific terms,
but you know,
I drive by Malibu here which is gorgeous
and all these rich people living on
these cliffs right on the water and at
the end of the day if something horrible
happened,
which of course we meet horrific
government would be then giving money to
people who chose to live there in a high
risk thing because their insurance
didn't go above and beyond whatever the
necessary of government requirements.
Okay.
So me and my family lives in this area,
so are laborers a couple miles from the
North Ridge earthquake and back in 1994.
And I know relatives who were just
calling up fema and say and give me
money,
give me money.
And they got money.
Like yell.
It didn't matter like how rich you are
or like what you had done or whether you
had built your home safely.
It's like,
like the,
like just the squeaky wheel gets the
grease.
Really all you have to do is pick up a
phone and so is that the real problem
with all of this that ultimately by
doing all of this regulation that you
punish people who do the right thing.
In a case like this,
there's someone who built their house,
earthquake safe,
bob invested their own money and all of
that.
Maybe had some,
maybe didn't.
Northridge
was a massive earthquake,
but then they're getting,
they're not getting government money
because they did the right thing and put
their own money in it.
Yeah.
So like.
Absolutely.
So it's not,
you know,
it's not fair.
It's not just economists would also
point out is that it's highly
inefficient because you're giving people
incentives to not do not do the right
things.
The other thing,
you know,
the end,
the final point is worth making is,
you know,
so I'm,
I'm the kind of person who defends
radical and extreme views,
but I never want to alienate people who
are a little bit less radical,
a little bit less extreme in all these
cases.
Uh,
like,
you know,
I still say,
look,
you know,
if you,
if you're very concerned about small
minority of very poor people who really
couldn't afford afford insurance during
this time,
that aren't fine,
have a government program that,
that,
that subsidize it or provides insurance
for orphan children,
for folio,
for kids who have terrible diseases for
people who are very poor but happened to
be struck by disaster.
You know,
you can have a program that costs five
percent as much as what we're currently
doing.
We could ride,
get rid of 95 percent without really
bumping into any of the complaints that
role people have.
I'll say like,
well,
what about,
what about the poor?
What about kids?
What about people that they're
responsible parents?
And still,
you could go 95 percent of the way to
the libertarian policy.
And again,
so know I'm the kind of person who says
what about the last five percent,
but I don't want to go and lose people,
lose people because who were willing to
go the first 95?
So it's worth saying,
look with health insurance.
All right,
well maybe we'll see how government
could still subsidize it for,
you know,
for kids,
the poor parents,
for people that are,
that we're born with a,
with a,
with a terrible congenital disease.
Like it just make a few exceptions and
then stop making the exceptions.
Say like this small area,
this is where it's so terrible.
Government's going to pay for it out of
taxpayer money.
Everyone else though,
Saker swim usually all like you're an
adult.
You should take care of yourself.
Yeah.
You Must Bang your head on the wall
every time people in public demand that
the government throw more money at
things,
right?
Because this is like,
it's always the easy answer.
It always see it feels right to people,
throw more money at it,
throw more,
and especially in the thrill and the
throwing is a great image because it's
just a lack of accuracy,
lack of lack of interest in actually
targeting any specific
no problem.
So,
I mean,
I've just wrapped up a book on education
called the case against education where
I argue for defunding education.
Right?
So,
yes.
I also like,
isn't that bad for you?
Well,
yeah,
it wouldn't be bad for me.
People listen,
but still my conscience says this is the
right thing to do.
Okay.
So,
so sell me on that.
I come from,
I went to a public elementary school,
public junior high public high school.
I went to State University of New York
at Binghamton,
which was hugely subsidized by the
government.
I think it was around $9,000
a year and I got a great education.
Uh,
why am I.
So I went to public schools right in
this neighborhood actually.
Um,
but yeah,
like the heart of my case is something
called the signaling model of education.
So you know this,
this is a fancy term for a common sense
idea,
just says that a lot of the reason why
education pays is not that as teaching
useful job skills,
but rather you're jumping through hoops
to show off for employers.
Right?
So just think about all the classes that
you ever had to take and then how few of
them are actually relevant to the job
that you do.
You actually probably have a job where
you do use more of a,
more,
more of what you studied.
You know,
I was a political sense.
Yes.
But yes.
But you know,
thinking about just think about all the
classes that were required were you
would not where you would not have been
allowed to graduate without going
through all of them.
So I mean I always have this example.
Imagine you're like one aristotle class,
shorter college graduation and yet you
want to finish that class.
Why?
Because you're going to use the
Nicomachean ethics and on the job
probably not.
Rather because you want that diploma and
employers are like,
like many employers will just throw your
application right in the trash unless
you have the diploma,
but do you lose something doing it your
way because of just a certain breadth of
knowledge.
Now I'm not saying that every class
should be mandated and of course they
stick you in things that shouldn't be
necessary,
but just that in terms of college
specifically that that's where you
should get a broad sense of knowledge.
Would that be at risk then?
Well,
here's the thing,
it's not at risk because almost no one
gets it.
Now.
That's the.
So that is the harsh truth is that you
just go and look at what graduates of
the current system.
No,
it is next to nothing.
Right?
So there have been some great nationally
representative surveys of what American
adults know about government,
about history,
about economics,
and the answer is they know next to
nothing.
So if you were to defend the system
saying that people need breadth of
knowledge,
well it's not a defense of the current
system because they have this current
system is not giving it to them all.
The way that I like to think about it is
that typical American college graduate
is lucky to maybe answer half of the
most basic questions you can imagine on
civics.
Now you might say,
well,
they then they.
That was still worthwhile.
I say it's not worthwhile because what,
what do you call someone who knows half
their letters?
What do you call someone who knows half
their letters and eating it?
It literally,
after letters,
you are illiterate,
illiterate,
even know what have your letters.
You are illiterate because you cannot
read similarly saying,
if you know half the basic facts about,
uh,
about us history or about American
government,
you don't know half of what you need to
know.
You just don't know it at all.
If you don't have a clue,
if you think there are one and a half
branches of government,
you just don't have a clue about what's
going on.
And that's what the current system has
given us.
So when people say like,
wouldn't this be a disaster?
And say,
well,
you might say the current system is a
disaster,
but what I'm proposing wouldn't be
worse.
Uh,
now there's always the question,
well,
but why not go and redouble our efforts
so that people really do learn the
stuff.
Main thing I'd say is like the resources
that it would take are so vast.
In fact,
I go,
I don't know of any actual sign that,
that,
that it,
that it could be done.
Uh,
and I,
you'll have,
I also,
I do have a way cheaper.
So a alternative to the current system
for actually getting people to learn
this stuff.
So this is,
this is one of my most reformers
proposals.
So it does involve,
it doesn't involve government money,
but it's still,
I'd say a way use the government money
than what we're doing right now.
Okay.
So here's the proposal.
Every year there is a government test of
your knowledge to civics.
And if you get a good score,
you get some money.
The end.
Alright.
Now what's the point of this?
Well,
two points,
first of all,
it gives people an incentive to actually
learn the material by how in whatever
means actually works best.
So in the end you get something.
Yes,
Angela?
Yes.
So like,
you know,
you could learn it on the Internet,
you can just read a book,
you could learn it in school,
like any possible method of learning.
The material is equally rewarded so it
doesn't go and throw money to high
school civics teachers who have
manifestly failed to fail to actually
generate a,
a knowledgeable public instead of just
opens it up.
So and so say there's a war for knowing
stuff.
However you learn it is fine.
But the other reason why you do it every
year is because there is enormous
evidence and educational psychology that
people generally forget what they
learned very quickly.
So on test day,
actually I believe that most of the
students in this class probably actually
kind of knew their stuff,
but what's what,
what psychologists called fade out is so
enormous.
Just the way,
like in one year out the next,
if you don't keep testing it,
you'll keep using it.
You lose it so you have the test every
year.
This would actually lead to retention of
knowledge over time where people would
not immediately forget the material as
soon as they learn it because like wow,
I need to know what next year and the
year after that,
every year I can get another hundred
bucks off of showing that I know my
stuff.
So.
And there's no,
you don't think there's a way to
prioritize that then.
So you can do with charity.
I'll be like,
this is legal and no charity has done it
for so I'm not too optimistic about that
happening.
But yeah,
like if some,
if some donor right now is interested in
doing this,
this would be great.
But anyway,
this will be so much cheaper than high.
Then all the high school social sciences
classes that we offer right now,
whatever you bros will ask,
people often start freaking out who's
going to write the test?
And I say,
well look right now a key part of civics
is knowing the answers the teacher wants
to hear.
So like even like as long as you know
that there's a certain bias on the,
on the official civics test,
you just vacate and like in order to do
well and it,
you still have to learn a bunch of
stuff.
So you know,
I mean I had so many college classes
where I disagreed with the professor.
I still learn,
I learned what the answer is they wanted
to hear,
but I also learned the material the same
time and there's no reason why you
couldn't do that.
Do apply the same thing.
So I don't,
I don't see that it's really such a.
Such a terrible deal.
Yeah.
I'd love to see the fadeout rate for
kids the day after the sats because I
remember studying for that thing and go
united tutor with a group of friends.
But I remember thinking,
man,
when I'm done with this thing,
I am going to let go of all this.
And I had taken the test probably a week
later.
I,
I'm probably to have the scores on that.
I mean this is some of the most
interesting research in psychology.
So there's a lot of research on fade out
in school where you go and you teach the
kids something and then you go and
measure it one or two years later in
school.
But the really scary,
really scary fade out is from school to
adulthood because of the kids in school.
At least they kind of know I'm going to
have to learn this again.
I might get tested on again.
But once you finally graduate,
that's it.
That's the end.
So there's a fantastic study,
a retention of higher mathematics
throughout life and like Algebra and
geometry,
like were they.
Within a couple of decades,
most people took those classes just know
or back to where they were before they
even actually started the classes.
The only people remember their Algebra
and geometry are people who go all the
way up to calculus to go all the way to
Canada.
Then you go and retain Algebra and
geometry for the rest of your life,
but you have to go way beyond a subject
to actually retain the,
retain the basics.
Any of that.
This all fits with like,
like,
like say,
like use it or lose it or a tiger mom.
Amy Chu has a great slogan like
everyday,
everyday you don't practice as a day you
get worse.
So you,
this,
this does go with well.
So why bother teaching people things
they're just going to forget.
Anyway,
so I mean this,
this is part of my critique of like,
like what's wrong with throwing so much
money at education?
You have to say we'll get like now of
course none of this denies that schools
do teach them useful material but again,
my view is already again,
so like for the useful material,
like you're like most people can pay for
it probably like most people's parents
can pay for it and then if there's going
to be any role for government,
let it be for the small minority of kids
whose parents are not able to take care
of them or shared.
He's not taking care of them.
And then for just that last sliver of
people let you know they don't like it.
There's going to be a role for
government.
Let it be that.
So don't throw money at a problem,
there's going to be money,
let it be narrowly targeted to give,
to be mindful that you are taking money
from taxpayers without their consent and
at minimum you owe them responsibility
to spend the money.
Well,
I think that's seems like a really basic
thing.
I think we've given up that that minimum
a long time.
Yeah.
But even like,
you know,
so it's one thing to say,
look,
this is so important that we're going to
that where that you have to pay whether
you like it or not too bad,
but then go and spend that money.
He Leslie,
that seems like it's really a true.
Like honestly,
like that seems like a true human rights
abuse.
To take someone for money at gunpoint
and then just blow it.
Like without saying,
well maybe this will do something.
Who knows?
Maybe if that's your attitude,
you shouldn't have taken my money.
You shouldn't be like,
maybe you should have asked me,
but you shouldn't have made me if that's
all you've got.
All right,
let's shift slightly from economics.
Which,
by the way,
I want to tell you that I think most of
my audience I think is classically
liberal or Libertarian,
I think is the,
is the big chunk of it.
So I think they're going to be with you
on a lot of this.
So let's get to some stuff that I think
that they may not be with you as much.
So let's talk about borders and
immigration for a second.
So are for a couple minutes at least a
year.
An open borders guy.
I am.
Yes.
So with everything going on in the world
right now,
give me your best pitch for open
borders,
which I am not.
All right,
let everything go.
I didn't know
y'all going on in the world.
So first step is to say the stuff you
see on the news is so statistically rare
that no sensible person would even worry
about it.
Very much.
So like terrorism,
like on the news all the time,
it is one of the smallest problems on
earth,
right?
So if you just go in and look at the
data and you'll.
And you will see alright,
so deaths from murder is like under one
percent of all deaths and terrorist
murders under one percent of all
murders.
So why is it that people are so worried
about it and we have spent over a
trillion dollars in the war on terror
because it has vivid because it is
emotionally effecting.
So I'd say like the first thing that we
have to do is calm down and apply
numeracy and just like say like here's a
problem.
Everyone's worried about it.
Is it really a serious problem that we
should be concerned about or not?
Right.
And you know,
I say like terrorism is probably the
most,
the strongest,
most emotional critique.
People have immigration and yet it is
not actually a sensible thing to be able
to be worried about it,
but how much and how much of it is
because what we're doing is actually
working so that we know we're keeping a
certain amount of people would love to
come in here and blow things up and
murdered.
What I'd say is there's,
you know,
there's a lot of ways that we could go
and test whether the stuff that,
that,
that we have is working.
Uh,
so there's,
there's,
there's a great political scientist,
John Mueller as a book called overblown,
going over all of it.
So one thing we can do is just look at
where called near misses so you can go
and see you,
right?
Like how many terrorist thoughts are
that failed,
which gives us an idea how fast,
how much is they go,
what we're currently doing actually
working.
So like the shoe bomber for things like
that.
So you know,
when you go and expand the sample to
all,
to all,
to all the failed cases and especially
when you go and look carefully,
not just the things that the government
classifies as terrorism so they can go
and get a photo op.
But things that actually when you really
look at was an actual terrorist plots
where they had gotten,
where they had done something more than
say we should have a terrorist plots
again,
is still.
It still remains incredibly rare.
Now another test,
uh,
this was actually one of my favorite
ones is for all the people think that
it's really easy to get into Mexico
should mean that it's really easy for
terrorists to get in from Mexico.
And yet the actual number that had done
this is exceeded extremely small.
Uh,
so in like,
in fact,
I'm not sure there's been any case of,
of any,
of any terrorists coming,
you know,
cross crossing,
crossing from Mexico and doing anything.
So again,
like,
you know,
so if you were someone who thinks that
the border is port is poorly guarded
right now,
then it doesn't make a lot of sense to
think that current anti terrorist
policies are preventing a lot just
because it's so easy for them to do
this.
Now,
I would say that our actually our,
our,
you know,
our borders guarded very well in the
sense that people pay about five,
about $4,000
to get smuggled across.
So for the kind of people who are,
who are smuggling or who are coming
across the border that several years
income,
it's a big deal,
but it's,
you know,
it's a big deal for a rural Mexican farm
worker,
but it's not a big deal for a serious
terrorist.
You're serious terrorist and you can't
come up with 5,000
bucks for your plot and then like you,
like you're a joke.
So,
I mean,
I'd say that.
So like the idea that there,
that there really is a serious problem
or that we have done much about it as I
think just wrong.
Uh,
this is like they're very,
you know,
so again,
that'd be going to settle again,
the stuff on the news and stuff that
people really care about now.
What is the case in favor of open
borders?
Again,
it's the kind of thing that you almost
never see on the news,
but.
So yeah,
so I mean there,
there's the others,
the economic case and,
and the human rights case.
So yeah,
like the economic case is very simple to
just says that the most,
all the very best way that we know of,
of,
of you increase in the production of
mankind is to move people from poor
countries to rich countries.
I,
yeah,
it is almost like magic.
You take a Haitian was making a dollar a
day and port-au-prince moved to Miami
and suddenly he's making $40 a day.
Alright.
So I was like,
his productivity increases by a factor
of 40 and you're like,
how is that possible?
Right.
You know,
so you'd probably doesn't even speak
English at first.
He speaks French and the,
the answer is his Labor is extremely
unproductive and Haiti and extremely
productive in the United States.
Even very unskilled workers produce far
more in rich countries.
And they do in poorer countries,
poor countries are screwed up in so many
ways.
So like,
you know,
this is one of the most amazing things
that you can do about poverty is to move
people from poor countries,
rich countries.
Then overnight,
what they can accomplish multiplies and
not by like 10 percent or 20 percent by
five times,
10 times,
20 times.
It is amazing and of course radiology
know if you understand the basic trade,
this doesn't just benefit the
immigrants,
it benefits everyone who's consuming
that product,
so the benefit benefits all of the stuff
that the immigrants make mead right now,
Haiti is pretty much irrelevant to the
global economy.
If you were to move those Haitians to
Florida,
suddenly the global economy would be
Richard by a very large amounts and in a
lot of the actual production will be
consumed not just by the Haitians,
but it would be consumed by,
you know,
by the people that are eating and
Haitian restaurants by the people that
are hiring Haitian nannies or rh
variation gardeners.
All these things that right now
currently are not happening now when
economists have just tried to get an
estimate,
like how much are we losing from these
border restrictions from trapping all
this valuable labor in poor countries.
You know,
a pretty good estimate is that we are,
is that immigration restrictions are
having the,
the production of the world we would be
with the world will be twice as rich if
anyone could take a job anywhere and
again it's things like what could you
accomplish in Haiti?
So you are actually,
you might be able to have to reset up
the revenue a hell of a show in Haiti,
although you'd have trouble getting your
guests so,
so cheap.
I could find.
Maybe I said it will be,
but in general,
most people when you picture what could
I do in Haiti,
it's very little.
I guess the main difference between a
you'll be,
oh,
so between Haitians and Americans is
that Haitians are stuck in Haiti and
yes.
So it's true that their skills are low
by American standards spots.
They can do so much more here than they
couldn't come.
They can,
they can do back at home.
So what now?
So what does act when people say open
borders,
what does that actually mean?
You mean that could people just wander
in from Canada and Mexico?
Are we shutting down the places that
they walked through?
So I would say that means that I would
call that no borders.
Okay.
I'd be willing to defend that too.
But that's not my main pitch.
My main pitch is open borders where the
way I think about it is if,
unless someone belongs in jail,
he can go.
He can move to any country wants.
He lived there and he can work there.
So unless blood.
What does that mean though?
So you.
Okay,
you're a Canadian,
you want to come to.
And as you walk through the sanction
border,
even though you said you might
potentially but the other thing,
but you walk through how you are you a
citizen,
they knew they would get,
like I said,
so you can live there,
you can work there.
It doesn't make.
It doesn't make you a citizen.
Right.
So maybe you're never miss out again.
And so like to me the heart of under
orders isn't citizenship.
It's the right to live the right to end
the and the right to work.
Right?
Which of course,
things,
you do this
for an unlimited amount of time because
then in effect,
you're probably going to get all the
rights of a citizen at some point.
Uh,
you might.
But,
so,
you know,
I,
I'm not,
I'm not against that,
but to get that is not to yell,
but I,
but I also not strongly for that.
Uh,
what I'm strongly for is the right of
any human being.
It doesn't belong in jail to live and
work in any country that he wants.
So again,
I already mentioned the economic case.
I mean,
do you need the human rights case is
basically what it look like.
This though,
this is a human being.
He wants,
sells like there's someone who wants to
rent them an apartment right here.
There's someone who wants to hire him
here.
What business is any stranger f saying
no.
So maybe.
So we know.
So I,
I have,
uh,
I've,
I've compared immigration laws to Jim
crow laws.
I said the main difference is that
immigration laws are worse.
Jim Crow Law said that there are some
areas where blacks couldn't live in the
United States.
There are some jobs blacks couldn't
take.
What our immigration law say is that if
you are a Mexican citizen,
there is no place in the country you can
legally live and no job in the country
you can legally work,
right?
That seems way worse than Jim Crow.
And again,
what's the difference?
So it will be,
will you have to become a citizen?
And then uk?
Yes.
Well,
but the only citizen is almost
impossible for someone,
for someone who's worn a Mexican
citizen,
unless of course you have a close blood
relative,
you are generally out of luck.
I mean sort of the idea of why don't
they just go and get in line.
The answer is for most people on earth
and want to come the line last hundreds
of years,
they could never legally come like the
conditions for legal immigration.
So they really all four,
if you are a low skill worker,
it's pretty much limited to having a
blood relative already the US or
marriage,
right?
Uh,
then,
you know,
there's a couple other way on,
a couple of other ways of doing it,
but those are extraordinarily rare.
So for most people in Third World Right
now,
there is no possibility they'll ever,
they will ever be admitted no matter
what.
Right?
And in,
to me it's like,
well,
why is it that because the person chose
the wrong parents,
they were born in the wrong country,
that they have to be stuck living in
Haiti their whole life and he and you
know,
so people can very easily see the
injustice saying because someone is born
black,
you are stuck living in black areas of
black areas of the United States and you
can only be a janitor.
You can only go and,
and we're uh,
and uh,
you can,
you can only work as a porter on a train
or something like that.
And it's like,
why is it that he has to be treated
differently just because he chose the
wrong parents?
And to me this,
this argument is a very powerful one.
And St.
Well,
how is that different from choosing to
have Haitian parents?
Of course,
the point is no one chooses parents.
You're just be all yell like it's
something that had happened before you
were born.
Why is it that a person,
if you can go and find a way,
a will,
a willing landlord find a willing
employer,
why can't you say yes to those jobs and
come and live here and work here we are.
So would there be an inherent problem
that if,
okay,
you let all these people in now they're
not citizens per se,
so they don't have the right to vote,
but they're here,
they're using our economy,
they're contributing to our economy,
all that.
All the good stuff that you said that
eventually we could get a situation
where you might have parody of the
amount of people
that are voting and the people that are
living here that seems like it could
become a problem.
Right?
So I mean again,
I would say it's not clear why they are
not clear why that's a problem.
Me and like one of the main things about
immigrants as they tend to be a
political.
So when you moved to a new country
normally like your concerns are,
I got to find a good place to live.
I gotta go,
I gotta go and get a job,
take care of my kids,
and getting involved in the politics of
the country is usually the last thing on
people's minds when they,
when they first,
when they first come.
I mean one of the strangest complaints
about immigrants to me is that they have
low,
low voting rates and I say,
well,
you know,
some.
I have some.
I think I've heard people say,
well first they got the wrong way and
second of all they don't vote.
It's like you pick one of the complaints
at least.
So I'm yelling in terms of what the,
what their kids will do.
So again,
so on your under current US law,
there's birthright citizenship.
So their kid,
their kids would be alive.
Say there is.
United States has a long tradition of
assimilating the children of immigrants.
It is.
Well,
it's worked very well for a rev American
history and people often think,
well yeah,
it worked back then back when we really
tried to assimilate them,
but it doesn't work anymore.
Where I can say is for the things that
we measure,
things are the things are as good now as
they were in the Ellis island days.
So especially for light,
for language competence,
it was never through.
We have something special here in
America that they don't have in Europe.
So for example,
I,
I agree with you there.
I think there's a lot of evidence of it
that people still do assimilate more
here,
but where Europe is having a problem
with assimilation,
which is a culture problem and that's
different,
right?
Right.
So two things.
First thing is I'd say that a lot of the
problems that people talk about are
primarily problems on television.
So there's an enormous amount of
simulation simulation going in Europe,
but that's not TV.
You don't go and have a TV show saying
you know,
enormous number of Pakistanis now like
soccer and root for Manchester United
and speak with British accents and had
British jobs and do regular stuff.
That's not a story.
Whereas you'll hear is here's a
neighborhood is a no go area.
Where were the regular British police
dare not travel for fear of what might
happen to them.
Sharia law,
my kid,
I'm gonna.
Come on at any moment the seminar might
come out.
That's a story.
All right.
So first step is always to separate
scary stories from Cisco reality.
And what I say is it is true that Europe
does a worse job of getting assimilation
of the US.
They still have a lot of assimilation.
I remember the,
like the last time I was in Paris,
I was just amazed at all these
simulation that I saw at his work and
walking downtown and seeing people from
all over the world,
but they're looking and acting French
now they,
they're smoking cigarettes in a French
way.
It was like wow,
she's drinking.
Right?
And it's like wow,
that guy looks like he's from,
from,
from Chad or something like that.
But,
but he's,
you know,
he has like the turtle neck.
So I mean like,
you know,
like you actually see a lot of
assimilation on.
Yeah,
I was truly have blessing simulation.
But they're a,
you're saying like,
is there something special that we have?
So there's nothing special we have is a
more restrictive welfare states so you
know,
so Europeans,
you know,
so again,
it varies a lot by country.
It's important important to it to
realize that.
But you're being.
Henry's in general do have much more
expensive welfare states especially to
make it easier be on welfare for your
entire life.
Right?
And I think this does,
this does great harm to their
assimilation because one of the best
ways of assimilating is to go to a job
and to go in or interact from Po with
people that aren't from your culture.
You know,
even if you know,
of course a lot of the workers won't be
even if all the workers,
if you go in and work in a,
in a,
in a chatty and restaurant,
even then a lot of your customers won't
be from Chad.
And so you will get to know them,
you'll interact with them.
Of course you need to go and let you
learn the language.
But also you get to know people.
And so this is the kind of assimilation
that has been greatly undermined by
your,
by European welfare states.
Again,
it's important to realize that there's
actually two kinds of things going on.
One of them is a lot of free government
money.
Another one is labor market regulations
that raised the price of labor that make
it hard to get a job.
And he put those two things together.
That's when you have a recipe for people
living their whole living their life on
it.
So again,
it's.
So you'd say,
well maybe they'll.
They might like to get a job,
but if it's really hard to get a job
because regulation and you get enough
money to stay alive,
that's where you are likely to say,
fine,
screw it.
I'm just going to go and live in my
ghetto and I won't and I'll never even
learned French and it's going to stay
here and I'm going to be bitter.
So people think that those things are at
odds with each other.
Open borders and a welfare state in a
way.
But basically you're saying if you,
if,
if you open the border and you took away
the welfare state at the same time,
you actually forced assimilation.
Yes.
So,
you know,
so you're not literally forced to create
conditions,
but the current system,
especially in Europe has heavily
subsidizing not assimilation.
Right.
And I think that's a mistake and you
get,
I think it's a case where people so
naturally scapegoat immigrants for the
problem when you didn't say,
well,
we have some really crummy laws which
actually would lead soil a lot of people
to go.
And of course plenty of people who are
native born free France who go about
who,
uh,
have their ancestors were galls.
Uh,
you know,
plenty of people like this are also in
France sitting around being supported by
the welfare state for their entire life.
Which again,
you know,
so important.
Remember,
it's not just people being lazy,
it's also being very discouraged that
the regulations make it so hard to get a
job.
Yeah.
So I,
I get your point a about the,
you know,
forcing once people are here and then we
put them on this and then they're sort
of stuck in that creates resentment and
then people in present them for that and
all that stuff.
Um,
what about the culture part of it that
there's,
we do have to acknowledge that cultures
are different,
that they respect different things.
They honor different things.
They not every culture is tolerant and
that we could eventually start bringing
in people who are intolerant of our
freedoms.
Right?
Regardless of whether that's overblown
on the news or not.
I get your point.
Yeah.
So I think it's overblown.
So I mean,
so again,
theoretically possible.
Yes.
Uh,
but um,
you know,
here's the striking thing all over the
world and the most progressive
countries.
What is it that they feel about culture
that you feel like America is destroying
their culture?
So in Iran,
they've long had this word they call
West toxification,
west toxification.
It's the idea.
There's all these horrible western ideas
flooding into Iran,
alienating your child read and
destroying Islam.
And here's why I say they're right.
Because when like La Western culture is
awesome,
people around the world love it,
especially young people and if
governments around the world want to
stop it,
they have to do the resort to extreme
measures in order to keep it out.
Right.
And what does immigration do at weddings
and brings the people who brings people
straight to the western culture where
their governments can no longer get
between them and the culture.
And the main thing that happens is that
people go native,
right?
So again,
they may,
they also get,
there's always some people on the news
who were refusing to do it,
but there are,
but there is a much larger group.
People who moved to the West and they
made,
you know,
they may pay lip service to their home
culture,
but they actually go and assimilate to
the new culture.
Meaning here's my favorite test.
If you want to go and find out how much
a simulation is there,
talk to any immigrant parents and what
will they tell you to immigrant parents.
So they are,
they say,
Oh yeah,
my kid loves us,
loves Romanian culture.
All he thinks about is Romania.
Romania,
all day being remaining is so central to
his life.
No.
What,
what,
what do you know?
So yeah,
my wife,
my wife is from a radio.
So the normal thing for your Manian
immigrant parents,
it's like almost any immigrant parents
is to say,
I thought we could preserve our culture,
but my kid just doesn't care about it.
I talked to my kid and Romanian and they
answer me back in English and my
grandkids don't speak a word Romania and
they have no interest in this stuff.
Right.
And again to say over the old video,
so I'll just do basically Americanism
where western is in.
Will actually wait.
Yes.
So I.
So I have a blog post called Western
civilization is a hardy weed and says,
look,
you know,
I believe in Western civilization much
more than most of the people who say
they defend it because I think we're
gonna I think we are winning right now.
And I think with open borders we will
win sooner,
right?
We'll,
uh,
and so many of this is the kind of thing
where someone,
someone watching it in rand might say,
ah,
he knew Kaplan had a plot by plot.
So yes,
I mean some,
I do think that Western civilization is
the better civilization in most ways.
I'm always happy to learn from other
cultures and to have a cosmopolitan
combination of all of the best things.
But nevertheless,
I think that when we compile all of the
best things in the world,
I think 80 percent of the stuff is going
to come from Western civilization.
Uh,
so maybe we'll pick up the work ethic
from China or something like that.
And we revitalized the work ethic.
So I think they've,
they've got something to offer there.
But what do like that about?
So again,
my plan is to go and spread Western
civilization more quickly and
effectively through immigration.
Right?
And I think I'd say it is working right
here,
right now.
I get to say like even Los Angeles where
people look around and say,
I don't see people assimilating.
You always look at,
well,
what is the generation of the immigrants
it?
It's a first generation immigrant.
Then sure they have an assemble aided.
They never did.
It was never true that first generation
immigrants became fluent in English if
they can't,
if they arrived in their twenties.
Right,
right.
They always had trouble.
They always stuck to the old ways.
Assimilation is always worked on the
second generation.
If you go and talk to a second
generation,
Mexican American in La,
the automobile speak fluent in English
or 90 percent.
Right?
All y'all so and even for even like kids
who were first generation,
as long as they came with their young,
so fluent English by far the norm.
So again,
I just been going,
going,
been going over this data so we can like
the main reason why we feel like
Hispanic immigrants aren't assimilating
and just because in the past it was
normal to have like one generation wave
of Germans and then it stopped.
One generation wave of Swedes are
Italians and then it stopped.
So then in a couple generations there's
no longer any Italian.
The Italians in America who don't,
who don't speak English,
but it's not because the first
generation learned English,
it's because the first generation died
and Italian stop coming.
So you know,
I don't again,
I don't see that again,
like when you understand what a
simulation is about,
it's about changing.
The second generation is still going on
at enormous levels.
So we are already the sizing Latin
America right now.
Yeah.
The wave part of this is interesting
because I think when people talk about
the Ellis island thing and they think
of,
you know,
like the lower east side of Brooklyn in
New York City,
Brooklyn,
you know from 60 years ago when all
these Irish and German and Jews and all
these other people came that yeah,
it was that first generation that had,
that worked incredibly hard,
barely spoken language,
lived more sheltered and then.
And then the rest of what you said
basically happened and they move
throughout the face.
All right,
let's do one more thing before I let you
go.
Passive,
isn't that my policy on this by the way?
Did Not look at the notes once,
which is a good interview.
Alright.
Uh,
so you've already done well passivism my
particular policy on this is that I
believe in a strong defense basically so
that we don't have to use it.
I don't want to nation build,
I don't think we should be all over the
place creating empires and all that,
but I do believe you need a strong
defense so that people won't mess with
you.
Yeah.
So how do you like that?
Well,
so if you want peace,
prepare for war anyhow,
ancient,
ancient Roman saying.
Um,
so,
uh,
just so we just want to sit back and
say,
you said what are you?
Oh,
so what is passivism and then what's the
art?
What is the argument for it?
So again,
my passion is my don't.
I don't mean never resisting violence.
So I don't mean that if someone is
coming in with an ax you shouldn't fight
back or anything like that.
Um,
so and so,
and I'll rather,
what I mean by passivism is opposition
to war,
right?
And so they'll stay organized,
violence organized by governments.
And again,
so what exactly,
how exactly is that different in any of
the answer is that war is actually
almost never defensive in the sense that
all of them were almost always involves
either deliberately murdering or
recklessly killing innocent people.
Right?
So this is really like,
isn't it theoretically possible that it
wouldn't be that way?
Sure.
But in practice,
anytime you fight any kind of a serious
war,
you either wind up deliberately
murdering,
murdering a whole bunch of civilians,
or you wind up recklessly endangering
them where you go when you drop a bomb
in the general vicinity of a whole bunch
of civilians and you killed them as
collateral damage.
What's the big deal?
You know,
if the police thought crime the same way
that the US government wages,
wages,
war on the USB,
oh this would be way bigger protest than
anything that we're getting right now
because you need to go in.
So I would say you're now,
I,
so I mean like so literally a minimum
just seems to me like there is some
moral problem with war.
So which again is glossed over by the,
uh,
yeah,
well,
it's,
we're just defending ourselves.
We'll normally,
you're defending yourself by sales,
by murdering a bunch of innocent people.
So,
you know,
at first glance,
this seems like it's a problem.
People often want to say no,
there's no innocence on the other side.
It's like there's no innocent babies in
the other country.
There's no one who has never done
anything.
It seems like this is a pretty flimsy
defense.
And then there's also the,
well anyone we kill is totally on the
hands of the bad guys that we're
fighting against.
It's like,
so really.
So like what if you went in like bomb
people in the neighboring country with
that beyond the hands of the bad guys to
like,
why exactly is it that like,
is there some limit to what you can
blame on the bad guys?
I mean,
it's one thing if you've got someone
holding a hostage right there and
they're shooting.
But again,
what if say there's just a bunch of,
there's a school next to the next to a
criminal.
Can you go and bomb the school?
Because.
Well,
it's,
that's on him,
you know,
the fact that we killed that to all the
kids in that school,
like the light sad,
but you know,
we were just trying to get that one
murderer St.
well,
anything that seems like a very flimsy
defense now again.
So like I am actually never an
absolutist.
Uh,
so I'm always willing to say,
right,
maybe we have to do this terrible thing
for the greater good.
Right.
So I always want to be open to that
argument,
but that's where I say,
all right,
well let's actually go and carefully
look at how much,
how,
how great is this good and how certain
can you really be the audits.
So,
uh,
you know,
so then you know,
just to back up.
So you know,
so anyway,
so like you know,
the,
you know,
the argument for bassmans first APP is
just accepting the harsh reality.
That war is not really defensive.
It does involve actually going and
murdering or at least man slaughtering a
whole lot of innocent people.
And like no matter the nicest country
wages,
war,
the most careful one does this,
that with modern weaponry will be hard
to do otherwise.
Can that,
can that be in and of itself moral
though,
like so in case in the case of World War
II where we weren't our homeland,
well Pearl Harbor,
but our,
our homeland wasn't threatened by the
Nazis per se,
by we killed a lot of people and the
allies firebombed,
Dresden and all that.
But we also have been saved a lot.
Again,
that's one of the like.
So that's that next step.
But again,
first step is just accepting that the,
that the United States government
murdered a lot of innocent key.
A lot of Sun innocent people.
They murdered in the United States
government murdered children,
right?
They did the kind of thing that we
attack terrorists for,
which is like,
which is murdering a bunch of innocent
people for the grill because you think
it's for the greater good.
And again,
normally when we,
when we,
when we attacked it,
when we say terrorists are terrible
people for this,
we don't have some big factual argument
about how what they're doing isn't
really for the greater good.
It's like you murdered innocent people.
That's a terrible thing to do,
right?
So you know,
it's just like there's at least a moral
presumption against this,
which maybe it can be overcome again for
the greater good.
But that's where I say that ceos.
So there's this great philosophical
example involving a doctor who's got
five patients a week,
you need a different organ donation,
and then a guy walks by who happens to
be perfectly healthy and the doctor
thinks maybe I should go and murder that
guy at harvest his organs,
and then he searches and he has no
family,
no one's really going to miss this guy.
I can save five lives by murdering one
person.
Seems like a good idea.
All right.
Now people's normal reaction to this is
horrible.
And the den.
And if you start brand new guy,
start ramping up the numbers.
Maybe it's a million people already,
but anyway,
at least that five to one ratio seems to
really bother people and say,
no,
you can't go and deliberately murdered a
person to save five other people.
All right,
so it is this.
It is this premise that I bring in,
in my case against war saying,
look,
all right,
now maybe that there's a,
there's a war for the greater good,
but are you actually getting something
like this five to one ratio,
right?
And furthermore,
how confident can you really be?
And that's right.
Bring in the last body of evidence,
which is that people's predictions about
the results of war are terrible.
So again,
the whole idea of prediction is you have
to say what you think is gonna happen
before it happens and then you look at
what occurs and see how accurate your
prediction was.
Alright?
So,
uh,
there is a fantastic political
psychologist named Phil tetlock who ran
a big experiment along these lines.
So in the 19 eighties he went and asked
a bunch of foreign policy experts their
predictions and then 20 years later came
back and weighed their predictions
against the actual results and they did
really badly.
Right?
And so this is experimental evidence on
people's,
but people's ability to forecast the
actual long run benefits of war are very
poor.
Of course we don't really need to do
experiments.
We can just go to the views about what
happened would have happened in Rwanda.
Rwanda were all sides are saying out of
the trenches by Christmas.
No one is saying I think this will end
in communist revolution.
And certainly no one was saying,
well I think the long run result of this
will be a communist regime in North
Korea.
A country doesn't even exist right now.
And yet if you know your history,
that is what it costs.
What would that is the key events in why
there's communism North Korea.
So now if you snap these pieces
together,
so moral presumption against more five
to one ratio or something like that,
minimum in order for it to be justified.
And then finally,
great uncertainty about what the effects
of war are.
That's where I get my case for
passivism.
It's like anytime there's a war,
anytime there is someone proposing more
by accident.
All right.
So like first of all,
so he's even,
isn't even a plausible that the,
that you are going to say five times as
many lives as you are going to murder
here.
And,
and is it reasonable to be that
confident given how bad most people's
track records are?
Right.
And if you put that together that I say
that for almost any actual war is really
hard to make the case and the case in
his favor.
So let's say there were some terrorists
in Tiawana firing rockets into San Diego
where you're writing in a couple of days
and they keep firing these rockets or
they're sending people in to shoot
people in San Diego or something.
You would be,
you would be for doing something.
Sure,
sure.
You're taking police action.
Absolutely.
Like normally it's actually not bombing
Tijuana.
I mean,
I think that's a case where as long as
they were Muslim terrorists and Ilana,
I don't think most Americans would
bombing tijuana even if the Mexicans
were floundering around and couldn't
figure out what to do.
I don't.
They also,
as long as the Mexican said,
you can go and send in America,
American troops to deal with this,
but don't go bombing us.
Don't go machine gunning whole villages
of people.
Also,
again,
some of you,
so I've no objection to anything like
that,
but anytime someone starts talking about
waging war with modern weaponry,
where you're going to start murdering a
lover,
you like Bernie inevitably murder or
manslaughter,
right?
Again,
salesforce and be murdered,
or you'd have to be trying to kill them.
Manslaughter is just when you recklessly
endanger them,
a buddy at anytime you're talking about
something like that.
That's where my past,
this group is getting in the way and I
think,
and this is another case where when
someone fights award and ends really
badly,
then it's like,
well,
what can you do?
But if someone opposes a war eventually
badly,
it's like,
ah,
passive.
It's a terrible idea like this one,
but like you have caused all these
problems,
you know,
so you know,
I would say,
look,
you know,
I think think it is a,
is a,
is a fair historical point to say almost
every,
almost every story and,
or anyone who knows any facts about the
world and say,
look,
just would have been better if any one
of the major powers to just rendered,
if any one of the major powers will
robot it just said,
look,
we give in you when we'll do what you
want and that would have prevented so
many terrible things.
Most obviously world war and yet people.
And yet people will say,
well look,
passivism would've led to disaster world
war two,
if we'd been this,
it wouldn't.
There wouldn't have been in world war
one.
So maybe we should get credit for that.
Right?
It's almost like the actions lead to
other actions.
Actions lead to other actions.
Now again,
notice what I'm not.
I'm not claiming that we have like no
clue at all about whether we're.
We'll do so.
So the uncertainty by itself doesn't
really argue for or against war.
It's the uncertainty combined with this
high threshold.
They're saying you've got to actually
know that you're saving five times as
many lives they're killing before we
should even be thinking,
even be talking about this.
And that's where the uncertainty is hard
because it is a barrier to war because
you like,
like saying it's a close call.
Well like say with Sandia passivism has
all close calls,
go to peace.
You don't doubt fixe if it's a close
call because you're murdering innocent
people.
So there's a very high threshold
responsibility.
Again,
you know,
so a higher even than the one of you for
spending taxpayer money,
you ought to know you're really doing
something good with it.
Right?
Well,
I have thoroughly enjoyed this.
We barely got into half of what I was
going to talk about where we're going to
do this again.
How about that?
Awesome.
Yeah,
that sounds great.
Yeah.
I really enjoyed this and I hope you
guys did too.
And for more of Brian's work,
you can check out be Kaplan.com
and it's Caplan with a c.
So it's B,
c,
a p l a n.com.